Hi.
In this video, we're going
to do some approximate
calculations using the central
limit theorem.
We're given that Xn is the
number of gadgets produced on
day n by a factory.
And it has a normal distribution
with mean 5 and
variance 9.
And they're all independent and
identically distributed.
We're looking for the
probability that the total
number of gadgets in 100
days is less than 440.
To start, we can first write
this as the probability of the
sum of the gadgets produced
on each of 100 days
being less than 440.
Notice that this is a sum of a
large number of independent
random variables.
So we can use the central limit
theorem and approximate
the sum as a normal
random variable.
And then, basically, in order
to compute this probability,
we'd basically need to
standardize this and then use
the standard normal table.
So let's first compute
the expectation and
variance of the sum.
So I'm going to actually sum up
from 1 to n instead of 100,
to do it more generally.
So the linearity is preserved
for the expectation operator.
So this is the sum of
the expected value.
And since they're all
identically distributed, they
all have the same expectation,
and there are n of them.
And so we have this
being n times 5.
For the variance of the sum is
also the sum of the variances
because the independents.
And so they're identically
distributed to the -- so we
have n times the variance of
Xi, and this is n times 9.
So now, we can standardize
it, or make it 0 mean
and variance 1.
So to do that we would
take these Xi's,
subtract by their mean.
So it's going to be 5 times 100
of them, so it's 500 over
the square root of the variance,
which is going to be
9 times 100 of them, so
it's going to be 900.
So that's going to be less than
440 minus 500 over square
root of 900.
So notice what we're trying
to do here is--
notice that the sum of Xi's
is a discrete quantity.
So it's a discrete random
variable, so it may
have a PMF like this.
And we're trying to
approximate it
with a normal density.
So this is not drawn to scale,
but let's say that this is 440
and this is 439.
Basically, we're trying to say
what's the probability of this
being less than 440, so it's the
probability that it's 439,
or 438, or 437.
But in the continuous case, a
good approximation to this
would be to take the middle,
say, 439.5, and compute the
area below that.
So in this case, when we do the
normal approximation, it
works out better if we use
this half correction.
And so, this, in this case,
probability, let's call Z the
standard normal.
And so this is approximately
equal to a standard normal
with the probability of standard
normal being less
than whatever that is.
And if you plug that into
your calculator, you
get negative 2.02.
So now, if we try to figure
out what this--
from the table, we'll
find that negative
values are not tabulated.
But we know that the normal,
the center of normal is
symmetric, and so if we want
to compute the area in this
region, it's the same
as the area in this
region, above 2.02.
So this is the same as the
probability that Z
is bigger than 2.02.
That's just 1 minus the
probability that Z is less
than or equal to 2.02,
and so that's, by
definition, phi of 2.02.
And if we look it up on the
table, 2.02 has probability
here of 0.9783.
And we can just write that in.
That's the answer for Part A.
So now for Part B.
We're asked what's the largest
n, approximately, so that it
satisfies this.
So again, we can use the
central limit theorem.
Use similar steps here so that
we have, in this case, n
greater than or equal
to 200 plus 5n.
And standardized.
So we have n and the mean here--
this is where this
comes handy.
It's going to be 5n and
the variance is 9n.
It's greater than or equal to.
5n's will cancel and
you subtract.
And then you get 200 over
the square root of 9n.
And we can, again, use the half
approximation here, half
correction here.
But I'm not going to do it, to
keep the problem simple.
And so in this case, this is
approximately equal to the
standard normal being greater
than probability of the center
of normal being greater than
or equal to 200 over square
root of 9n.
And so same sort
of thing here.
This is just 1 minus this.
The equal sign doesn't matter
because Z is a continuous
random variable.
And so we have this here.
And we want this to be less
than or equal 0.05.
So that means that phi of 200
over square root of 9 has to
be greater than or
equal to 0.95.
So we're basically looking for
something here that ensures
that this region's
at least 0.95.
So if you look at the table,
0.95 lies somewhere in between
1.64 and 1.65.
And I'm going to use 1.65 to
be conservative, because we
want this region to
be at least 0.95.
So 1.65 works better here.
And so we want this thing, this
here, which is going to
be 200 over square root of n--
square root of 9n, to be bigger
than or equal to 1.65.
So n here is going to be less
than or equal to 200 over 1.65
squared, 1 over 9.
If you plug this into your
calculator, you might have a
decimal in there.
Then we just pick n,
the largest integer
that satisfies this.
So we can plug that into your
calculator, you'll find that
it's going to be 1,632.
That's
part B. Last part.
Let n be the first day when the
total number of gadgets is
greater than 1,000.
What's the probability
that n is greater
than or equal to 220?
Again, we want to use the
central limit theorem, but the
trick here is to recognize that
this is actually equal to
the probability that the sum
from i equals 1 to 219 of Xi,
is less than or equal
to 1,000.
So let's look at both directions
to check this.
If n is greater than or
equal to 220, then
this has to be true.
Because if it weren't true, and
if this were greater than
1,000, then n would have been
less than or equal to 219.
So this direction works.
The other direction.
If this were the case, it has
to be the case that n is
greater than or equal to 220,
because up till 219 it hasn't
exceeded 1,000.
And so, at some point beyond
that, it's going to exceed
1,000 and n is going to be
greater than or equal to 220.
So this is the key trick here.
And once you see this, you
realize that this is very easy
because we do the same steps
as we did before.
So you're looking for this, this
is equal to, again, you
do your standardization.
So this is from 219, and you get
5 times 219 for the mean,
and 9 times 219 for the
variance, less than or equal
to 1,000 minus 5 times
219 over square
root of 9 times 219.
Again, you can do the half
correction here, make it
1,000.5, but I'm not going to
do that in this case, for
simplicity.
So this is approximately equal
to Z being less than
whatever this is.
And if you plug it in,
you'll find that
this is negative 2.14.
So in this case, we have this
is the probability that Z--
again, we do the same thing--
is greater than or
equal to 2.14.
And this is 1 minus the
probability that Z is less
than or equal to 2.14.
And that's just phi of 2.14--
1 minus Z of 2.14.
And that's--
if you look it up on the
table, it's 2.14.
It's 0.9838.
So here's your answer.
So we're done with
Part C as well.
So in this exercise, we did
a lot of approximate
calculations using
the central--